- [Interviewer] All right, De'Angelo.
- Yes, sir.
- [Interviewer] De'Angelo,
where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [De'Angelo] I was born
in New Orleans, Louisiana.
Raised in Las Vegas, Nevada.
Came out this way after
the Hurricane Katrina.
You know, so I'm basically west coast.
- [Interviewer] And you're
currently based in L.A. or Vegas?
- No, Las Vegas, Nevada,
but I've been back and forth
from Los Angeles and Las Vegas since 2012,
since I got out of prison.
And because my other baby mom,
she's from Swan, she's from out here.
And then I have another baby on the way
with my new baby mom, and stuff.
So that's why I'm in California.
Other than that, I'm Vegas bound.
- [Interviewer] And your
new baby mama is Faith,
who I interviewed a week or two ago.
- Yes, Ma'am, I mean yes, sir.
I'm phew-phew in.
- [Interviewer] (chuckling)
And you're a gang member?
- Yes, sir.
- [Interviewer] Which gang?
- I'm from West Side Playboy Bloods.
1721 Curran Way.
- [Interviewer] So you're Blood.
And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- No, sir.
My mom, when she was born,
basically when she was pregnant with me,
she had lupus cancer,
so she had no strength
for her legs, and stuff,
basically due to the drugs
and stuff that she was doing
when she was pregnant with me.
She absorbed this cancer, so,
they told her that I would never
would of been able to live,
whatever, so they started
giving her steroids and stuff,
and she kept doing drugs and stuff,
and when I was born in
1993 in New Orleans,
she basically she got, the
cancer took over her body more,
and she started to like losing her cells,
and her hair started falling out.
So, as everybody else is a kid,
growing up knowing their
mother and their father,
I had to go see my mother at a hospital,
all up, from all the way up
to 2001 and when she passed.
Like I never seen my mom like regular.
Like anybody else, like they go to store,
I always got to see my
mom on a hospital bed.
Even to the day she died.
So, and my father, I
don't even know of him.
I know of his name, but I don't know him.
And but, he's of Chicago, a
native out of Chicago, a GD.
And I don't know him,
he ran out on my mother
when she was pregnant,
and pretty much I was just
raised by the streets and stuff
once my mom passed away in 2001.
Family took me, only because
there was a state check,
when she was, she worked for
the state, before I was born,
so once I passed, I mean, once she passed,
the family felt like the only reason
for me to be around, is for,
they can accept this check.
So it really wasn't no love.
I was just there for a check, you know.
So, basically the streets raised me.
- [Interviewer] You
joined a gang at what age?
- I started gang-banging like
around six years old, sir.
- [Interviewer] Six?
- Yes, sir.
- [Interviewer] Ah.
And you've done prison time?
- Yes, sir.
- [Interviewer] What kind
of stuff got you in prison?
- You said, what kind of,
what did you say, sir?
- [Interviewer] What did
you do to get in prison?
- I was involved with one of my friends,
he's just now getting released now.
We had basically committed an act.
It was a murder, but a
conspiracy to murder.
A friend of ours, we were young, you know,
and do dumb stuff, I had stole a car.
And we had seen the guy
that who had shot my friend
a few weeks ago, and had shot
his sister on a school bus,
and me having a young mentality
ways, and not thinking,
and just like thinking
I'm young and talented,
and not giving a damn.
I basically provoked my friend into,
let's go hurt this guy.
Like he hurt your brother, like so,
why you still got him
walking type, so, so.
I provoked him until I basically like,
basically, how you say the word?
Like, um,
um, um, ah,
when you like basically when
you trying to get somebody
to do something, and
they don't want to do it.
- [Interviewer] They don't want to do.
- Basically yeah, that's
basically what I did.
He didn't really wanna do it,
but I was so amped up and
angry at the situation,
I'm like yeah, you gotta do this.
- [Interviewer] You talked him into it.
- Yes, sir.
So we drove down the little
street, a dark street,
we seen him walking on,
and I told him to hop
out and start shooting,
and he hopped out and start shooting,
and the guy lay, he died,
basically, you know.
And they caught me later on,
throughout, like a few weeks later.
Through my friend, 'cause he told on me.
Which he was supposed
to, because it was wrong,
you know, in all actually,
we know at the funeral,
like we think we're
gangsters and all that,
but we are no right from wrong.
That was wrong.
And I felt like I needed to
be caught, and I got caught.
And I was 15 at the time.
Certified as an adult
in the state of Nevada.
They had Nevada revised
statues, that's NRS,
so they have their own laws.
So you can go to prison as a teenager,
in the state of Nevada.
And I was released when I was 18,
which was 2012, and came
out here to California,
and been living both lifestyles.
But, I haven't been gang-banging no more,
nothing, sir, after that
life situation right there.
I started off real young, and stuff,
like real, real young.
And I'm 27 now.
- [Interviewer] How did you meet Faith?
- I met her through off of,
basically off the website, man.
On Facebook, man.
You know I usually don't even be clicking
on my friend request things.
And I so happen, just clicked
on the friend request,
I said, you know, when you
see a pretty white girl,
or something, it's fake,
in Facebook, or something.
So I'm like, damn, let me
go, I'm bored, you know.
Tripping with my baby mama, anyway,
let me go ahead and click on
this and see if it's real.
I clicked on it, boom, she messaged me.
I'm like, oh, this fake,
this is why, you one
of them Arabian people
in other countries with
fake Facebook accounts.
So I'm like, damn.
So I clicked on it, boom.
I messaged her, like where are you?
She like, I'm in California City.
I'm like, whoa, I've been to
California City before, boom.
So I'm like, damn, that's crazy,
so we started connecting
and talking over the phone, first then.
She believed that I wanna
go come and get her.
And come see her in person,
which is, the show, you
believe, is "Catfish",
you see on MTV.
So I had to come show her
I was real, you fib me.
Actually it was granted,
I had to pull up on the
process of me getting to her,
I had went to jail for my partner,
he was speeding in Rosemont.
I went to jail, she believed I
flaked on her, and all types,
so she was believing
like the show, "Catfish",
he's not real, he's not coming.
So I ended up getting out,
coming back to L.A. County,
getting on the train,
to actually getting a
ride to California City,
and that's when I actually met her.
No, no, no, I actually met her,
she was already gone
out of California City,
she was in Vegas waiting on me.
And that's when I actually met her,
when I went to Vegas,
and that's when we met.
- [Interviewer] So Faith will do business
in both Vegas and L.A.?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And as her boyfriend,
you just kind of, you do what?
You just?
- Oh man, I hustle.
I gotta hustle, it's hard.
You don't understand, I'm
from New Orleans, man, like.
We can't sit around broke, you know, like,
not even broke,
especially in the society
of the world we live in.
There's two reasons to come outside.
Make money and spend money.
If you ain't doing that,
ain't no reason for you to be breathing,
or coming outside,
you're just a bad entity,
and that's what us, as a people,
needs to surround ourself
around good, positive people
that's willing to make
money and spend money.
We get ourself caught
up throughout the day
around people that's not,
with none of that on their mind.
It's just straight
demonic stuff, you know?
So, we gotta keep forward,
keep our mind on a hustler's standpoint.
You know, a heart like,
keeping money in our pocket,
you know, somebody need, some
in need, help them, you know?
Just having that godly
spirit in us, you know?
'Cause all of us are
not perfect, you know,
and we just gotta have that good.
We all know right from wrong.
So that's my goal everyday, as you know,
is to make money and spend money.
If it ain't that, I try to stay away
from all of them type of entities,
get away from them people.
New (indistinct) is all bad people, man.
- [Interviewer] And you
have a baby on the way?
- Yeah, baby on the way, another one.
That's my fourth one, man.
Fourth one.
- [Interviewer] Did you
raise the other kids?
- Did I raise the other kids?
Me personally, with like how most people,
I never got the opportunity
to raise none of my kids.
Like, because of the lifestyle I live.
Like, this is my first time
just settling down with women,
and actually having
girlfriends, and stuff.
'Cause I was really into the gang-styling,
into really taking a life,
and to really making a
person not exist no more.
Like, that's what my whole motto,
until I started learning,
and expanding my brain,
and realizing it's the point of life,
and I just taking other people lives,
and listening to other people,
who situations,
and reacting off of their
situations, you know, so.
- [Interviewer] Do you have regrets
over some of the things that you did?
- Yes, sir.
Yes, I regret everything I had done.
Like, I pretty much,
I learned the point in my life to where
I started blaming a lot,
but again, I learned to not blame it,
take the responsibility for my actions.
You know, so, whatever I do,
I take responsibility of my actions now.
I used to, you know, I used
do the self-pity me thing.
And feel sorry, let my own
feel sorry for me and all that.
I don't have that in me no more.
Like, I learned to take
advantage of my own situations,
and take responsibility
in my actions, you know?
And not blame others
for nothing that I own.
I don't do crimes with other people.
I don't do anything,
I never told on nobody in that situation.
But I've been told on before, but I-
- [Interviewer] How does karma
play a role in your life?
- It's big, it's big.
Karma is a big, big thing, you know?
A big, big, big, big, big one.
She's a big bitch.
Man, like, the biggest bitch
you know on the street.
You know, that's why I try to treat her
as good as possible.
You know like, this Karma,
she come out of nowhere.
Her big ass just hopping the street,
she hog up traffic every time.
You know, like, and I'm that taxi driver,
you know, I'm not stopping.
I'm that New York taxi
driver, I can't stop.
There's too much going on,
too many people, you know?
So, I try to treat people how
I wanna be treated, you know?
And try to keep a smile on my face,
even though I have an evil look, you know?
But God is good, you know?
- [Interviewer] And what's the,
now that you're out of the gang life,
and you have a child on the way.
What do you see for your future?
- Man, I see a lot.
You know like, I see my
own business, you know.
I just need to get this money, right?
Start saving money, you know, like but,
the society we live in, you
gotta spend some type of money.
But I need to learn myself
to start putting like
a hundred, $200, set aside.
$300, set aside, and just put
it in a sock, or something,
and act like some wrong happen,
act like it's some bill
money, or something.
Because I spend a lot of money.
Wherever I go, I spend money.
I don't hold onto money.
I don't even like money.
It's the root of all
evil, so I'll spend it.
- [Interviewer] Are you working?
Are you getting a job,
or anything like that?
- I don't have a job right
now, so I hustle, sir.
Which I have my I.D. now,
I'm in the process of
trying to get my social,
and everything,
but everybody got these
family-owned businesses now
due to Corona, and they shut down
all the major corporations, and stuff.
So the small businesses,
sort of major corporations
can come in and take over, you know?
But again, it's just something
I'm thinking about of doing.
I'm trying to start my
own business, you know,
once I settle down,
which I am settled down,
to get my life on the
right track, which it is.
I just need to surround myself
around more positive energy.
You surround yourself
around 10 broke niggers
you gonna be the 15th broke purse, family.
So I'd rather surround myself around
a lot of positive people that hate me,
and despise me, and everything.
But it's still gonna rub off good aura,
because I'm around positive people,
even though they hate me, you know?
And that's what I learned
to not let people,
I don't care what they
say of me, you know?
'Cause that ain't, that's one of our sins.
We curse with sin,
we're not even supposed to see, you know?
So, not having to throw religion in there,
and all that religious,
that's one of my things I know of life.
So, I don't take this, looking at sin,
me looking, and everything, it's a curse.
So I know when it's that time,
I'd be forgiven for me, for sin, you know?
If anybody understand what I'm saying,
you understand that.
- [Interviewer] Are
you in love with Faith?
- Yes, sir.
That's my whole world.
She's the reason I walk around,
and I get up every day with a smile.
And motivation to doing anything positive,
and I have a baby on the way.
And she's a beautiful woman, she's smart,
she intelligent, and she just
put ourself down through,
because of the situation
she'd been through, you know?
And I try to let her realize like,
it's humans on this earth,
and the time we're living in,
everybody mind is
expanding and opening up,
and this is what God's people,
he's expanding, he's
blessing us with, you know?
So, and that's why I'm trying to get her
to realize that I'm one of
God's treasure, you know?
And I really wanna-
- [Instructor] Are you
comfortable with her
going out and making
money the way she does?
With other guys?
- Me personally, of that
lifestyle, me personally no.
I hate it.
And it is, and me personally, I hate it,
and I hate pimps, I hate people like that,
that force women to do that.
But again, when a woman needs to do that,
I feel like she needs to
keep her money for herself.
And if she is doing that,
she need to keep her money for herself,
and build herself up,
instead of getting used,
and her giving that money to another man
that don't even know her.
And that's basically using her,
and basically, he has a
whole lifestyle at home.
He's not forcing his baby
mama to come out there,
and do this, that who has his kids.
You get what I mean?
It's a cycle, women like don't
know their values, you know?
Like, I be damned, if I'm a prostitute,
and I go down here, and I'm making money
for another person, I
gotta give it to him,
and his kids, and his family, and stuff.
And I'm not good with myself,
and I don't even have no where to stay,
you know what I mean?
So it's just a psychological game.
When people, those men attack women,
like this low, low self-esteem,
they don't care about themselves,
don't wanna go out.
Like when they go outside,
they feel good about
themselves, or something.
Because they feel like somebody like,
somebody tell them they
were beautiful today.
You know, somebody told
them they were sexy.
Somebody turned around with
that extra look, or something, you know?
They feel good about that stuff.
A man always telling them
what they need them to do,
and this is how they get money, you know?
So, me personally, I
don't respect that game.
You know, but I respect the hustle
of getting the money part.
Other than that, the giving
the money to the man,
and like you know, him
holding onto the money.
You're an adult, you
can make your own money.
You're the one who made it.
You'd be dumb if you give your money.
That'll make him like saying,
like you, he's a human and counted.
That's crazy-
- [Interviewer] But it's a very
dangerous lifestyle for her.
- Dangerous, it's real dangerous.
- [Interviewer] You're okay
with her going out at night and-
- No sir, I'm not okay.
I get nervous, and everything, every time.
Man, it's just, it's her free will.
Pimps have the thing,
I'm a pimp and all that.
Because they're forcing somebody.
- [Interviewer] There's pimps
and then there's hustlers.
And I think there's a
fine line between the two.
- Yeah, there for more, you know.
And that's if how, she
feel like she gets money,
and she wanna do it, that's her bill,
not myself, no, don't
go out there and do it.
Like me personally, I'll
rob, and kill, and still.
But I'm learning better to expand my mind
to it's better ways than
getting money, you know?
- [Interviewer] And you guys are staying
in motels right now?
- [De'Angelo] Yes, sir.
- [Interviewer] And when the child comes,
what do you think you guys will do?
- [De'Angelo] Well, by then, I'll have,
you know, I'll have an apartment by then.
You know, and everything.
'Cause I'm pretty much in this,
like this program with the GR thing.
And hoping they come through with
what's called a pilot program.
Where they help you with an apartment.
And basically the homeless out here,
they help them with apartments.
For the people that's really trying
to get apartments, you know?
That's not playing with them.
And then so, that's pretty
much what I'm gonna do.
Get into the pilot program,
so that I can get into, have
an apartment for myself,
and my newborn, you know,
so I can actually take care of my child,
now that I have, you know?
'Cause I never got the real opportunity
to even sit there and
take care of the child
of my past baby mama, because
of situations, you know?
And I think it's a
blessing that I have her.
- [Interviewer] So this
will be your fourth child?
- [De'Angelo] Yes, sir.
- [Interviewer] The other three are with?
- [De'Angelo] The baby mamas in-
- [Interviewer] How many-
- [De'Angelo] Two of them are in system.
- [Interviewer] How many
different baby mamas do you have?
- [De'Angelo] It's only two.
- [Interviewer] Two.
- [De'Angelo] Two women.
- [Interviewer] And two of your kids
are in the foster system?
- [De'Angelo] Two of 'em.
One of them is not really my kid.
I basically took like,
she was pregnant with 'em,
and stuff, and I loved her so much,
and me being the type of man I am,
I'm not gonna leave a woman out there,
that especially if I'm messing with her,
and I know she's pregnant,
and I know it's not mine.
So when the child was born,
I put the child, pinned
my last name on the child,
as you know.
So I consider her as mine, too, you know.
- [Interviewer] What
would you say is the most
important lesson you've
learned in your 27 years?
- The most important lesson
I learned in life, period,
is to loving yourself.
They trick us every day
with reading, school.
Everything else.
Distractions, vibration
music, to love other things.
To make us to forget about
ourselves, period, ourselves.
Like this is how they control the world.
Like, to get you to
idolize something else.
A tattoo, an image, false imagery.
We do all these things, we gotta do this,
and worry about all our
things throughout our day,
and we forget about
ourselves and our creator.
And that's where we
get ourselves messed up
to where we hate ourselves,
and imaged the media,
the entertainment, the TV,
we idolized those things.
But we don't love ourselves.
So, the biggest thing in my life
is learning how to love myself.
Put a smile on my face, you know.
And to keep that, you know?
Because a lot of people
hate that, you know?
And we forget that
we're spirits, you know?
That's how your heart is beating.
That's how I'm looking at you,
and that's how I'm
communicating with your soul.
I say it's a blessing that I
learned how to love myself,
and find out the truth of life,
is just loving yourself.
And they give you the tools every day.
With vibrations bless all the things.
And vibrations and things to get you
to forget about yourself.
You read a book, you reading
about something else.
You're not worried about yourself.
So, my biggest thing is self reserve,
and loving yourself, and loving yourself.
Whatever it is that they feel bad about,
they say they don't love themself.
So that's why they have that, you know?
And that's not right.
And they trick you with those.
And they tell you to go
to these programs, AAAU,
that you sick, and that
you're not all the way there,
and all that, but you're not crazy,
your good, not crazy, you know?
Nobody crazy.
That person that's speaking
to himself, he's not crazy.
It's just his spirit is lost right now.
They ain't nothing but a trapped entity
that God already got us out of here.
- [Woman] Is there a bathroom in here?
- [Interviewer] Straight back.
- You know?
- [Interviewer] The green
exit sign on the right.
- And everybody that's
done, that's why I walk,
and she get mad at me
when I walk pass people,
and I tell a random person, man,
love yourself, you got a beautiful,
you beautiful out here,
and the person will look at me crazy.
Like, damn, what is he talking about?
Love yourself, man, they
tricking you every day
to not love yourself.
Get you away from your
creator, love yourself.
If you don't love yourself,
you gonna fall for anything.
You gonna start thinking
about other things.
You're gonna idolize what?
You gonna take on other energy.
Start, man, man, I don't like you,
because you don't love yourself.
You know, you're supposed
to love yourself.
Wake up in the morning, damn, I love,
wash your face, that's why
that mirror is right there.
So you can look at yourself.
Oh, I'm right there, get these
eye boogers out of my face.
Brush my teeth, you know.
You know to love yourself.
We don't even do that in this timeframe.
We wake up, smoke a
cigarette, or something.
Or listening to the news, Coronavirus.
Cover up, stuff like that.
God is good, man.
He giving everybody the
strength and the tools,
to get back with him.
But again, remember you're
in a spiritual warfare, man.
Where the evil is gonna
try to outdo the bad,
but you need bad to do good.
I ain't no more, but it's not even that.
It's just I found out the truth man,
just loving yourself, man.
You gotta drink up.
Yes, sir, I apologize.
- [Interviewer] That's for you.